[Music]
i wonder if you could recapitulate a
little bit of your thoughts on on life
as information which which i believe you
touched upon in a previous book um but
uh what what is life uh to answer uh the
uh if you can answer schrodinger's
question left unanswered in his book
life does seem pretty remarkable to a
physicist i think i said earlier it's
like magic
what a life
needs or what genetic information needs
it needs some stability if it's to be
handed on from one generation to the
next shouldn't be thermally disrupted so
it needs to be have the properties
stable property of a crystal
needs to lock in
its structure
but it needs
crystals don't contain any information
they're just periodic structures
and so what you need to encode
information is to have to break the
symmetry as we've talked about earlier
and you have
irregularities of some sort and here and
so the idea of an aperiodic
crystal is exactly it's an information
rich stable molecule it's just what dna
is and because of the four-letter
alphabet of dna
you can encode a staggering amount of
information
in a strand of dna but it is it is
relatively stable it's not disrupted by
thermal uh fluctuations uh at room
temperature so that that was uh pretty
good but i don't think he answered the
question i think he hoped that somehow
quantum mechanics would come to the
rescue after all quantum mechanics
explains all other matter but it sort of
curiously can't explain living matter
but
rather more adventurously
and i take this as
the jumping off point for my own recent
interest he said that we must be
prepared to find a new kind of physical
law prevailing in it by et men living
systems
not just a new physical law not just uh
you know alongside maxwell's equations
and so forth
we've got you know schrodinger's life
equation a new kind of physical law to
actually directly answer your question
what is life i would say
it's a sort of catchphrase but a lot of
people people use that life is chemistry
plus information
the essential thing about life it's not
any mishmash a bit
it's actually information which is uh
organized and which can bring about uh
the
organization of matter in other words it
serves a management role if you measure
information in bits of shannon taught us
many decades ago it doesn't somehow
capture uh the contextual nature of
biological information
so
for example if we've been talking about
dna
take a gene
what is a gene well it's um
a set of instructions for ribosome to
make a protein for example but you can't
tell by looking at a particular sequence
of dna whether it's instructional
information or just junk
you just shuffle the bits you couldn't
tell it's only in the context of the
system as a whole
that you can tell that that information
is instructional
that it is functional the scales you
can't decompose it in the same way that
we like to in physics it's a systemic
property so we need information which is
which is potent only in the context of
the system as a whole and there has to
be a molecular milieu that can interpret
those instructions and act on it so
we're into this sort of
dodgy area like you know semantic
information and meaning and so on that
the uh
instructions in dna have to mean
something to the organism and
philosophers jump on you to say well you
can't use terms like meaning and so you
sort of slide around with the
terminology but there's no getting away
from it that we're dealing in living
systems with not just shannon bits
but with something that goes beyond that
that we have not yet properly captured i
don't think yeah
and of course that does evoke uh
concepts of creation and the ultimate
teleological entity
and all
knowing i'm the present uh omniscient
omnipotent creator and i do want to
pivot there that's why i'm not a
conventionally religious person
that's number one and number two is that
as a scientist i don't have to uh
say well this is the way it is and i'm
not going to change my mind and so i'm
interested in the issues and the
concepts um that you can't work in areas
like cosmology where you ask questions
like what happened before the big bang
uh what is the nature of time and then
you go to quantum physics what's the
nature of reality and then you go to
life what is life and then what is
consciousness you know all those things
which i love to think about you can't
think about those without coming up
against those same age-old questions
that for centuries were part of religion
you can arrive at a conclusion while
there's something going on or as i
prefer to say there is a
a rational scheme of things uh that
science is busy uh unraveling that the
universe is uh um is not just
uh hodgepodge of odds and ends it is a
coherent uh scheme that we can come to
understand and i think that's deeply
significant so you you through your
science you can arrive at a position and
if that happens to concur with some
particular religious point of view well
then that's of some interest but what
you absolutely don't do is decide in
advance what you want to believe i think
there's a god that did this and that and
shoehorn the scientific facts to fit and
i'm afraid there's far too many people
in that latter category they've already
made up their minds that they believe in
a particular type of god and uh the
worst example is of course um the
so-called god of the gaps so if uh if
somebody is convinced uh that there is a
god and god created life um and they'll
turn around and they say well you
scientists can't explain the origin of
life so therefore we need god i mean
that's that's an appalling line of
reasoning you know i like to talk to
theologians some of them are very smart
you see some some
if you think about 500 years the
greatest intellectuals were actually
theologians and mathematicians
and these people
dealt with these really tough topics
like if there is a god is god within
time or outside of time and can
something come from nothing
and you know why does mathematics work
and how you know they thought very
carefully about those things
and i have found uh
found that you know entertaining and
sometimes productive to revisit some of
those old arguments we're all engaged in
trying to explain the universe and then
religious people say well it all goes
down to god and then you say well how do
you explain god well god doesn't need an
explanation well that's no good but then
they turn it around and say what do you
think and i think well the laws of
physics seem to do a nice job or where
do they come from
what's the origin of those and i say oh
well most scientists don't like asking
that question they they just sort of
accept it as given and they say well
point made you know we we both have a
what i sometimes call a levitating super
turtle that holds the tower of turtles
up i was taught paul by uh by many
eminent uh scientists in my career that
you should never ask why as a scientist
you should only ask what how when
um you know etc but uh but you asked
this question i want to ask it back to
you what do you mean by why is that a
legitimate uh question for legitimate
physicists such as yourself to even
countenance ask it oh well of course you
you can ask what you like and i
strongly encourage uh that scientists
should ask the why question even if we
know that in
coming up with explanations we're we're
really dealing with the how because
it why is of course rather ill-defined
term
but it very often carries the
connotation of on purpose you know why
did you do that and if we caught out
doing something we shouldn't then we
come up with excuses right or why can't
i do that and the parent always has to
say because because i said so we have
these arcane
procedures of you know building weird
machines and doing peculiar stuff to
matter that maybe has never been done
before and writing funny symbols on
blackboards and bits of paper and sort
of figuring out how the world works and
it's been just spectacularly successful
had what three and a half centuries of
really doing much more than just
describing the world that's not what
theoretical physics does it just it
doesn't just give an account to the
world it explains the world it leads to
an understanding you see the point
about asking the why questions it leads
you to that aha moment that ah i've got
it now i see how it's put together and
we would like to believe i'm sure all of
us are driven by this passion to explain
the world um that there are reasons for
why things are as they are that there
will be you know three generations of
particles and
all of these other things that if we
work a bit harder there will be that aha
moment now it'll make sense
but of course there's only an act of
faith it may be that the universe
doesn't actually make sense or doesn't
make sense to a human being after all
what we call common sense and what we
arrive at as understanding is something
that has been
selected by uh
evolution that we've evolved uh through
natural selection to survive in the
proverbial jungle and yet we're equipped
with this cognitive ability to not just
observe the world but to
understand it at this deeper level of
reality i consider that pretty
stupendous yeah and it may be we just
had a dream run that we've had a few
centuries where we've been really good
at this and we're going to soon hit a
brick wall and the whole enterprise will
grind to a halt i really hope that isn't
the case i really do think we can go
further and that there is some some
underlying order that we're
not not quite getting that we're missing
at this stage and that's for the next
generation
we need help to understand what's going
on